[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin schönen guten Abend katja
ist wieder mit mir im Studio zeigt uns
später einige Champions
die Themen an diesem Mittwoch an
Revolte bei den Republikanern das
us-repräsentanten aus stürzt seinen
Vorsitzenden McCarthy mit Stimmen aus
dessen eigener Partei
Asylkompromiss in der EU Staaten mit
besonders hohe Migrationsdruck sollen
Asylsuchende Länge an den Außengrenzen
festhalten dürfen
unglückliches Heimdebüt Union Berlin
unterliegt Sporting Braga in der Fußball
Champions League
[Musik]
wir starten in die Sendung mit dem Blick
in die USA und einem politischen Vorgang
den es so noch nie gegeben hat das
US-Repräsentantenhaus hat seinen
Vorsitzenden abgesetzt den Republikaner
Kevin McCarthy das Besondere er wurde
von seiner eigenen Fraktion gestürzt
damit steht im US-Repräsentantenhaus in
dem die Republikaner mit einer knappen
Mehrheit des sagen haben erst einmal
alles still und er ist für die Rebellion
verantwortlich mit Gates der 41-Jährige
zählt zu den Hardlinern der Republikaner
ist glühende Anhänger von Ex-Präsident
Trump und hat jetzt mit sieben weiteren
Republikanern und den Demokraten
geschafft den eigenen Mann aus dem Amt
zu jagen und die eigene Partei zu
spalten über das Chaos mit
weitreichenden Folgen
seinen politischen Triumph zu Lasten
seiner Parteifreunde der Putschist aus
Florida treibt seit Monaten die
Republikaner vor sich her
Kevin sollte es endlich kapieren er hat
15 Wahlgänge gebraucht um überhaupt ins
Amt gewählt zu werden er war schlecht
nach acht Monaten ist nun endlich
Schluss eine historische Absetzung wir
sollten einen besseren finden
erstmals
Repräsentantenhaus einen eigenen
Sprecher abgewählt es ist eine Blamage
für die Konservativen der Posten ist
nicht mehr besetzt
in der Debatte zuvor die überwältigende
Mehrheit der Republikaner gegen die
Absetzung ihres vorsetzenden doch der
Abgeordnete GATS der die Vertrauensfrage
gestellt hatte zeigte sich unbeeindruckt
am Ende stimmten lediglich acht
Republikaner mit den Demokraten gegen
bekannte sie führen hier heute ein Drama
auf es geht ihnen nicht darum Probleme
zu lösen unseren WLAN zu helfen wir
müssen aber für Amerika eine Option ohne
Drama sein der abgesetzte Parteifreund
wenig später ihm wurde vorgeworfen dass
er mit der Opposition einen Deal
ausgehandelt hatte um vergangenes
Wochenende in letzter Minute den
regierungsstillstand abzuwenden
ich bereue nicht verhandelt zu haben in
der Politik muss man Kompromisse finden
Koalition bilden Lösungen suchen das ist
richtig ich habe gelernt Probleme zu
lösen nicht sie zu erschaffen
die Republikaner
zerstritten das Land lahmgelegt ein
Nachfolger noch nicht in Sicht
unser Mann in Washington heißt Elma
teven Elmer wie handlungsfähig ist die
Politik denn in dieser Situation
also die Handlungsfähigkeit hier im
Repräsentantenhaus ist gleich null
solange kein neuer Sprecher gewählt ist
das hat mir gerade noch einmal ein
demokratischer Abgeordneter bestätigt
keine Gesetzesvorhaben können beraten
werden vor allen Dingen nicht der
wichtige Haushalt wenn der nicht bis zum
17 November verabschiedet ist für das
kommende Jahr dann hat die US-Regierung
kein Geld mehr zu vergeben dann gibt es
auch keine Ukraine Hilfe mehr Hilfe für
die Ukraine und der Abgeordnete sagte er
könne nicht verstehen wie die
Republikaner der Putin helfen können
statt einer Demokratie wieder Ukraine
nächsten Mittwoch soll hier dann die
Wahl für einen neuen Sprecher
stattfinden aber man muss seinen
Kandidaten finden der eben den radikalen
genehm ist einer von ihnen kann es wohl
nicht sein weil die anderen sind sauer
weil eben man so mit McCarthy umgegangen
ist wenn es ein moderater Republikaner
wäre dann hingehe er aber am Ende
genauso wie mit Kaffee wie eine
Marionette oder wie eine Geisel von
diesen radikalen ab also die
Republikaner müssen hier beweisen ob sie
überhaupt noch reg ierungsfähig in der
Zukunft sind danke für diese Einordnung
nach Washington Elma und um das Chaos im
Capitol und was der Machtkampf bedeutet
welche Folgen das alles haben könnte
darum geht es um 19:30 Uhr auch bei ZDF
heute live auf unseren Social Media
Kanälen und in der ZDF heute App
nach Europa im Streit über eine
asylreform haben sich die EU-Staaten in
einem zentralen Punkt geeinigt der
sogenannten krisenverordnung die räumt
Staaten die unter besonders hohem
Migrationsdruck stehen Sonderregeln ein
so sollen Asylsuchende an den
EU-Außengrenzen bis zu vier Wochen unter
haftähnlichen Bedingungen festgehalten
werden können auch niedrigere Standards
bei Unterbringung und Versorgung sollen
möglich sein mehr erfahren wir jetzt von
Gunnar Krüger
was ist der Laub in einer
flüchtlingskrise die Verordnung die das
regeln soll ist Teil einer großen Reform
das Ziel das gemeinsame europäische
Asylsystem die Reform wird irreguläre
Migration in Europa wirksam begrenzen
und starten wie Deutschland dauerhaft
entlasten verspricht der Kanzler und
nennt den Durchbruch historisch doch
Experten dämpfen die Hoffnung Beispiel
Italien und die geplanten
verpflichtenden grenzverfahren Italien
kann die gar nicht durchführen und hat
auch kein Interesse daran diese Menschen
festzuhalten ohne irgendeine Aussicht
egal wie das so viel Verfahren ausgeht
irgendwie zurückzuschicken das ist also
keine sinnvolle Maßnahme vor diesem
Hintergrund Asyldebatte am Vormittag in
Straßburg ein rechtsnationaler Italiener
sagt so wie seine Regierung private
Seenotrettung sei gesteuerte
migrationlich dass die deutsche
Bundesregierung auch noch das Geld
deutscher Steuerzahler in die Taschen
steckt die diese illegalen Boote
betreiben in diesem Punkt gab Italien
nach in anderen hat das Parlament noch
Redebedarf das Parlament muss jetzt
dafür einsetzen dass in diesem komplexen
europäischen asylsystemen am Ende auch
die Situation besser ist dass es also
bessere Verteilung zum Beispiel gibt
dass die Menschen an den Außengrenzen
registriert werden und das ist an den
Außengrenzen auch rechtsstaatlich
abläuft viel Zeit für die Verhandlungen
zwischen Mitgliedstaaten und dem
Parlament bleibt nicht im Juni wird neu
gewählt
und noch eine wichtige Entscheidung hat
die EU heute getroffen der
niederländische Christdemokrat huxtra
soll neuer klimakommissar werden er
bekam im Umweltausschuss des
Europaparlaments eine zwei Drittel
Mehrheit nach einer Stunde langen
Befragung hatten die Abgeordneten ihre
Entscheidung zunächst verschoben
bedenken gab es wegen hochstrass
beruflicher Vergangenheit beim Ölkonzern
Shell morgen muss noch das gesamte
EU-Parlament zustimmen
das Kabinett hat grünes Licht für das
Klimaschutzprogramm von
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck gegeben es
umfasst 130 Maßnahmen habeg räumte ein
dass das voraussichtlich nicht ausreicht
um die Klimaschutzziele bis 2030 zu
erreichen es würden dann immer noch 200
Millionen Tonnen CO2 zu viel ausgestoßen
moderne und vorbeugender soll der Kampf
gegen Volkskrankheiten wie Krebs oder
Demenz werden dafür will
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach ein neues
Institut schaffen darin wie uns Britta
Spiekermann gleich zeigt soll dann auch
die Bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
Aufklärung aufgehen und an die erinnern
sich viele auch deswegen
manchmal muss man über Dinge offen und
laut
1990 in Zeiten von AIDS der richtige Ton
gegen Angst und Verunsicherung
inzwischen ist es still geworden um die
Bundeszentrale in der Pandemie spielte
sie kaum eine Rolle dafür gab es viel
Kritik jetzt soll die Behörde übergehen
in ein neues Bundesinstitut Aufklärung
und Kampagnen zentral gesteuert werden
es bestehe Bedarf sagt Lauterbach unser
Gesundheitssystem ist geprägt durch sehr
hohe Kosten eine durchschnittliche
Lebenserwartung und eine mangelhafte
Vorbeugung Medizin Männer werden im
Schnitt 78,3 Frauen
83,2 Jahre das ist europäisches
Mittelfeld Haupt Todesursachen sind
Krebs und Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen
vieles sei vermeidbar
Gesundheitsbewusstsein müsse in der
Bevölkerung verankert werden auch die
Gesundheit von Kindern und Jugendlichen
steht im Fokus
Schuleingangsuntersuchungen hätten
ergeben dass die Kinder in Deutschland
durch die corona-pandemie vermehrt
übergewichtig sind und psychomotorisch
und soziale Defizite haben hier brauche
es neue Strategien und Hilfen auch
müssten Gesundheitsämter besser
koordiniert werden auch das
Robert-Koch-Institut soll einen neuen
Zuschnitt bekommen sich ausschließlich
auf Infektionskrankheiten konzentrieren
der afd-vorsitzende copala ist während
einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung in
Ingolstadt ins Krankenhaus eingeliefert
worden nach Angaben der Partei hat es
einen täglichen Vorfall gegen ihn
gegeben die Polizei vor Ort bestätigte
lediglich Ermittlungen was genau
vorgefallen ist ist noch unklar
kurzer Rückblick ins Corona Jahr 2020
für knapp eine halbe Milliarde Euro
vermittelte Andrea Tandler corona-masken
an Bund und Länder und verdiente dadurch
Millionen weil Tandler die Tochter eines
ehemaligen CSU-Politikers ist war von
Filz und betrug die Rede haltbar waren
die Vorwürfe nicht aber die
Staatsanwaltschaft München wirft ihr
Steuerhinterziehung im großen Stil vor
vom Prozess Auftakt berichtet Petra
Neubauer
Andrea Tandler will das Bild von der
abzockenden politiker-tochter gerade
rücken bittet aber auch ihr Gesicht
nicht zu zeigen es geht um einen
pikanten Deal bei dem sie und ihr mit
Angeklagter Partner 48 Millionen Euro
Provision für maskengeschäfte kassiert
aber nicht sauber versteuert haben
sollen die Steuerhinterziehungen
betreffen insgesamt
23,5 Millionen Euro sind drei
Steuerarten betroffen nämlich die
Einkommensteuer die Gewerbesteuer und
die Schenkungssteuer Deutschland zu
Beginn der corona-pandemie Masken und
Schutzkleidung sind knapp da soll
Tandler die Tochter des ehemaligen
csu-generalsekretärs Gerold Handler ihre
politischen Kontakte eingesetzt haben um
ein Geschäft zu vermitteln für hunderte
Millionen Euro verkauft eine Schweizer
Firma vor allem Masken an die
unionsgeführten Gesundheitsministerien
in Bayern NRW und dem Bund die Affäre
beschäftigt an den
Untersuchungsausschuss ist aber an sich
nicht Justiz iabel nicht geht ist die
Frage der moralischen Bewertung von
massengeschäften im Zeitalter der
Pandemie dafür sind Gerichte in
Deutschland nicht zuständig
möglich sagt Tandler heute dass ihr in
dieser hektischen Zeit damals Fehler
unterlaufen sein es ist aber auch ganz
eindeutig dass es meiner Mandantin zu
keinem Zeitpunkt um irgendwelche
Betrügereien ging sondern das ist
ausschließlich darum ging über die
Erträge aus den Geschäften mit PSA eine
neue berufliche Existenz aufzubauen acht
Verhandlungstage hat das Gericht
angesetzt und Klarheit in diese
Geschichte zu bringen
mit großen Hoffnungen im Gepäck sind
viele Gläubige nach Rom zur Welt Synode
gereist Hoffnungen die katholische
Kirche möge konkrete Reformen zu lassen
aber Papst franziskus stellte direkt zu
Beginn klar man käme nicht zusammen um
einen Reformplan voranzubringen bis Ende
Oktober beraten Vertreter der Kirche
über einen neuen Umgang mit
Homosexualität und den stimmberechtigten
Mitgliedern sind zum ersten Mal
überhaupt auch Frauen Andreas poste
aus allen Teilen der katholischen
Weltkirche sind die gut 365
stimmberechtigten Mitglieder nach Rom
gekommen es geht im Kern um die Vision
des Papstes von einer offenen Kirche für
alle
in einer komplexen Zeit wie der unseren
ergeben sich heute neue kulturelle und
pastorale Herausforderungen die eine
herzliche und freundliche innere Haltung
erfordern damit wir einander ohne Angst
begegnen können
erstmals in der Geschichte der
katholischen Kirche haben Frauen bei der
Synode eine Stimme
ein besseres Ansehen hätte weil ohne
Frauen wäre die katholische Kirche
glaube ich nicht machbar auch wenn in
Rom der Synodale Weg der deutschen
kritisch beugt wird fühlt sich deren
Vorsitzender bestärkt die Frage der
Frauen die Frage der geschlechtlichen
Vielfalt die Frage von Segnungen die
Frage von Beteiligung die tauchen fast
überall auf der Welt in ähnlicher Weise
auf und suchen nach Antworten den
konservativen geht der gesamte Prozess
bereits viel zu weit dagegen fordern
Opfer sexualisierter Gewalt endlich
strukturelle Konsequenzen aus dem
Missbrauchskandal hier kommen Bischöfe
aus aller Welt zusammen und wenn sie
über die Zukunft der Kirche nachdenken
dann müssen Sie diesen Skandal zunächst
mal zur Kenntnis nehmen bis Ende Oktober
wird viel über Strukturen debattiert
wer jetzt schnellere Formen erwartet
wird enttäuscht werden denn der Papst
möchte zunächst über die Strukturen
reden möchte die verändern damit die
Inhalte anschließend besser besprochen
werden können Papst franziskus wünscht
sich von den Teilnehmenden der
weltsenode mehr Stille Reflexion als
öffentlichen Disput Ausgang offen
[Musik]
ungewöhnlicher Vorgang heute beim Chemie
Nobelpreis schon vor der Verkündung am
Mittag waren die Namen nämlich
durchgesickert geehrt werden drei
Wissenschaftler die in den USA forschen
Woogie war Wendy Louis Bruce und
alexejimov sie entdeckten und
entwickelten sogenannte Quantenpunkte
das sind sozusagen künstlich hergestellt
der Atome die können leuchten und damit
etwa Krebszellen sichtbar machen
außerdem erzeugen Quanten Punkte
gestochen scharfe Bilder in Bildschirm
und kommen in superschnellen
Quantencomputern zum Einsatz
ein Tag in Venedig morgens rein abends
mit dem Bus wieder raus aufs Festland wo
die Übernachtungen günstiger sind ein
solcher Tagestrip endete gestern Abend
für mindestens 21 Menschen tödlich der
Bus verunglückte stürzte von einer
Brücke und brannte fast vollständig aus
unter den Opfern sind auch deutsche wie
das Auswärtige Amt mittlerweile
bestätigte über die schwierigen
Bergungsarbeiten Annette hilsenbeck
Gedenken an der Unfallstelle für die 21
Opfer der Tragödie
eine Überwachungskamera hat gestern
aufgezeichnet wie der Bus die Leitplanke
durchbricht und abstürzt etwa 15 Meter
tief ein Zeuge schafftes kurz darauf
noch ein Kind und eine Frau zu retten
ja die haben wir rausgetragen als wir da
rein sind habe ich viele Menschen
übereinander liegend gesehen es war
schwierig sie rauszuziehen da war Blut
auf den Kleidern überall
die Batterien des elektrobusses wurden
beim aufprallen Brand gesetzt feuerwehr
und Rettungskräfte kämpfen mit den
Flammen nach bisheriger Erkenntnis
stammt ein Todesopfer aus Deutschland
doch noch sind nicht alle identifiziert
das ist deine Katastrophe eine Tragödie
wir sind dann viele Verkehrsunfälle und
Tragödien gewöhnt aber das war ein
schlimmer Anblick dieser brennende Bus
der voller Menschen war die 15 zum Teil
schwer verletzten Passagiere wurden in
Krankenhäuser gebracht unter ihnen soll
auch ein Deutscher sein derweil hat die
Staatsanwaltschaft Ermittlungen
aufgenommen
wir sammeln in dieser Phase alle
Elemente die wir finden um zurück
konstruieren was passiert ist und wir
verfolgen bei unseren Ermittlungen keine
vorgefasste these
in Venedig steht man unter Schock der
Bürgermeister hat drei Tage Trauer
angeordnet
gerade volljährig geworden und los mit
dem Zug durch Europa und das auch noch
kostenlos die Europäische Kommission
startet die nächste Runde des
Reiseprogramms des Cover EU und
verschenkt insgesamt 36.000 Zugtickets
wer als Gewinn will muss sein Wissen in
einem kleinen Quiz unter Beweis stellen
und dann kann es losgehen bis zu 30 Tage
lang quer durch den Kontinent mitmachen
kann wer 2005 geboren wurde
so jetzt zur Champions League Katja und
gestern der Abend den hatte sich Union
Berlin aber ganz anders vorgestellt
definitiv es war echt bitter Spieler
Trainer und fast 70.000 Fans in Berliner
Olympiastadion waren ziemlich gefrustet
und Union Berlin verliert das erste
Heimspiel in der Königsklasse quasi in
letzter Sekunde zwei zu drei ging's
Sporting Braga aus Portugal
Ratlosigkeit bei Trainer Fischer schon
wieder verloren in der vierten Minute
der Nachspielzeit der entscheidende
Treffer für Braga unions zweite
Niederlage in der Champions League haben
wir irgendwie was falsch gemacht haben
wir den Fußballgott irgendwie beleidigt
dass wir aktuell so behandelt werden ich
weiß es nicht ehrlich gesagt ich meine
Schläge kannst du noch einstecken das
ist so ein bisschen
die Frage dabei läuft es zunächst sehr
gut für die Berliner sheraldo Becker mit
dem 1:030 minute das erste Tor für Union
in der Champions League das
Olympiastadion bebt denn er trifft
gleich ein weiteres Mal nur 7 Minuten
später 2:0 nach dem Anschluss noch in
der ersten Halbzeit gleich Prager durch
Blume in der 51 minute aus doch statt
einer Punkteteilung muss Union das drei
zu zwei durch Castro kurz vor Schluss
befinden nehmen 0 Punkte in der
Champions League nächster Gegner SSC
Neapel
ja die Bayern haben beim FC Kopenhagen
2:1 gewonnen dank der Tore von Jamal
museala und matissel und dank des
Keepers wenn Ulrich der in der
Nachspielzeit den Sieg mit einer
Glanzparade sicherte die Bayern
ausführlich und natürlich auch die
Partien von heute unter anderem mit dem
BVB gegen AC Mailand und RB Leipzig
gegen Manchester City im Champions
League Magazin von 23 Uhr an
die Fußball-WM 2030 wird eine die es so
noch nie gab denn erstmals werden die
Spiele auf drei Kontinenten in sechs
Ländern stattfinden genauerer sind das
in Europa Spanien und Portugal Marokko
und Afrika und Uruguay Argentinien und
Paraguay in Südamerika mit dieser
Vergabe wolle man so der
Fußball-Weltverband den hundertsten
Geburtstag der Fußball-WM global und
einzigartig feiern und noch zum Turnen
bei den Weltmeisterschaften in Antwerpen
haben die deutschen Männer im Team
Finale Platz 6 geholt geglänzt hat dabei
vor allem Lukas Dauser am Barren der
30-Jährige untermauerte mit der
bestpunktzahl von
15,366 Punkten seine Favoritenrolle für
das Einzelfinale am Sonntag nach zuletzt
Silber bei Olympia und der WM und einer
langen Verletzungspause teilt er jetzt
ganz klar die Goldmedaille an
let's go Baby sagt er okay danke schön
Katja wir gratulieren jetzt noch zu
einem runden Geburtstag 50 Jahre
auslandsjournal das heißt 50 Jahre
wöchentlich die weite Welt erkunden vom
Wilden Westen bis hin zum wilden Osten
hier das Oktoberfest chinesische Version
da sehen was und ob in Krisengebieten
oder in er friedlichen Flecken der Erde
die
zdf-kolleginnen und Kollegen sind
mittendrin immer gefordert oft ist es
mühsam manchmal tut das auch weh und ähm
ja Rückblicke und neues gibt's dann
heute um 22:15 Uhr wir sagen Glückwunsch
auf weitere 50 Jahre von wo auch immer
ihr alle berichtet
so wir hätten noch die Lottozahlen und
die gehen so 18 19 28 38 43 46 Superzahl
lautet 9 und alle Infos zum Nachlesen
auf lotto.zdf.de und auf der ZDF Text
Seite 557
das Wetter das gibt's gleich mit den
terli
21:45 Uhr ist heute journal Zeit dann
mit Marietta Slomka schön Mittwoch Abend
der sich ein bisschen anfühlt wie
Montagabend danke fürs Interesse und bis
morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter größten Teils
herrschte derzeit hoher Luftdruck von
Spanien bis nach Deutschland aber diese
Kaltfront hier erreicht hauptsächlich
den Norden und bringt durchaus kräftigen
Regen mit ja und wie geht's weiter eine
neue warmluftblase macht sich auf den
Weg vom Atlantik wo das Meer ja deutlich
zu warm ist kommt die Wärme Richtung
Mitteleuropa und da sind tatsächlich
wieder 30 Grad möglich in der kommenden
Nachteil allerdings die Kaltfront im
Norden mit Regen und Hals Gewittern
kräftigen Wind aus Südwest als Sturm im
Süden gibt es Nebel dazu Temperaturen
dort und drei bis vier Grad hier also
schon deutlich kälter als z.B im
Nordwesten mit 14 Grad ja und morgen
dann kräftiger Regen im Norden das lässt
im Tagesverlauf nach nach Süden hin
zeigt sich häufiger die Sonne bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 16 halt 21
Grad im Südwesten die Temperaturen sind
im normalen Bereich die nächsten Tage im
Norden gibt's immer wieder Regen sonst
aber Sonnenschein nach Nebel vor allem
17 bis 23 Grad am Samstag bis 26 und
Sonntag bis 28 Grad ein schöner Abend